thank you don't know everything about me
yes I do you don't know I'm drunk right
now
[Music]
[Music]
last two minutes of the premiere are
mind blowing yes oh yeah
no they really Harper was your reaction
when you read it um part of it I didn't
read because it was omitted from the
script I made it from your script even
my script but it's okay because I knew
I'd read it what it was but it was like
disjointed and I knew I knew what was
happening but when I mean when I read it
I was like wow this like this is this is
big this is powerful but this is
everything that we want from this show
from these characters everything that we
want out of Jack and Rebecca and and
Randall and Kate and Kevin and and
everyone it's just it's what we want to
see we want we want to get back into
back into the world of you know his
family big clue revealed how do you feel
like audiences are gonna feel going into
Episode two I think people just need to
pay attention like really really pay
attention because you'll start to pick
up on indicators you'll see some things
that maybe you haven't seen before and
if you're paying attention to it then
you're going to pick up some clues as to
timeline as opposed not in addition to
events so yeah you just got to pay pay
close to ten page close attention it's
like a game of Clue I think that they
did a remarkable job it's not the full
answer it's not the full story I mean
because we have 18 episodes to sort of
tell that in and for that to unfold and
it's a very you know monumental pivotal
moment in the lives of this of this
particular family so it can't just like
all come out
[Music]
you